[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
he knew
what is this place
the room we require
i trust you all have the tickets that
bunty gave you
you'll need them to gain access to the
ceremony what do you think newt
can you tell which one is yours
no
good i'd be worried if you could i
assume the chilean's in one of these
cases yes
well which one is it which one indeed it
was like a three-card milani thing
like a shell game thing
like like a short con
never mind it's a muggle thing
memory is everything
without it we are blind
[Music]
without it we leave the plate of our
world to chance
[Music]
i'm sorry to disturb you promise but
i've just received troubling news tell
me what is it it's grindelwald
our time is closed my brothers and
sisters our wall with the knuckles
begins
today
the world as we know it is coming undone
if we're to defeat him
you'll have to trust me mr kowalski we
need you i said it on and out and i went
out
you do know i'm a witch right
dumbledore said i give you something
jacob
[Music]
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous music in a
century
who wouldn't like our chances
oh
no one can know everything
not even you
what are you doing is madness
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
dangerous times
favor dangerous men
if by tea time all of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
mr kowalski my pleasure
[Music]
do you really intend to turn your back
on your own kind
it was you said we could reshape the
world even if we make mistakes
we can't try to make things right
[Applause]
[Music]
we're gonna need some help
[Music]
there's nothing you can do to stop me
[Music]
things are not quite what they appear
[Music]
i trust you're enjoying your wand mr
kowalski
can i keep this
[Music]
[Music]
you